what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
a tic toc compilation called feminist
tiktok before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay wait i'll move that there
also follow my instagram it's just
pearly things with the z
at the end patriarchy will do everything
they can an amazing quote by andrea's
work in
in which she says the argument between
wives and [ __ ] is an old one
each one thinking that whatever she is
at least she is not the other
this quote is one of my favorite quotes
in feminist theory ever because it
highlights such a huge part of modern
misogyny oppressors within the
patriarchy will do everything they can
to invalidate the oppressed
this is done by creating a system in
which nothing we do is accept it
everything we do is seemingly a
byproduct of our womanhood
and therefore invalid so long as they
can validate us for every interest
every belief every opinion they can
invalidate our experience and our
existence
this is essentially why i have no idea
what she's talking about i'm a girl
i don't i don't subscribe to whatever
theory she's talking about
so many men on this app claiming that no
girls could have any real interests
and whatever they do is simply to gain
the attention and attraction of cis men
we must fight to dismantle these thought
processes okay i'm
i got a lot of interests and i've never
in my life been told i have them
because men maybe on youtube like a
random youtube comment
when i react to like nanosphere stuff
but in general no
oppressors and if you were someone who
upholds the patriarchy you must think
twice before participating in this
misogynistic rhetoric
many people get really surprised when
they discover how the majority of the
ancient greek greats actually viewed
women so here's a quick recap
starting it off and keeping it simple we
have seminaries who described women as
the worst plague zeus ever created
then we have pythagoras who states there
is a good principle creating order light
and man
and an evil principle creating chaos
darkness and woman
then we have good old socrates who
claims that all the pursuits of man are
the pursuits of woman also but in all of
them women are inferior to men
and then aristotle who believed that
women were mutilated men
and that the female character was of a
natural deficiency
and then we have mananda who claimed
that he who teaches women letters
feeds more poison to the frightful asp
and at first all these are very funny
because they're old and feel like
they're from a time beyond our own
and then you realize the long-term
effects this type of thinking had on
women's education and learning
and then it just becomes tragic okay
here's why men think women aren't funny
pretty sure these studies were only
sister oh my gosh i
i had this thought the funniest women
are never as funny as the funniest met
like i can't think of a girl that's as
funny as kevin hart and this is coming
from a girl
i think i'm kind of funny i mean i would
give myself
a 10 in terms of phony but i'd say i'm
i can at least get a chuckle you know
but
tiffany haddish that's the funniest
female i think
that i would i can think of but i
wouldn't put her close to kevin hart
even
well though so here are your grains of
salt so across the board men and women
said that it was important to them in a
long-term relationship that their
romantic partner have a good sense of
humor
but when researchers asked what they
meant by a good sense of humor
women defined it as a man who makes them
laugh whereas men defined it as a woman
who laughs at their jokes
a separate study reiterated that men
think it's more important that women
laugh at the jokes that they make rather
than women making jokes of their own
yeah and of the men who said
i think every person does that do you
guys have that friend
that laughs at every single joke and you
love them
until you tell the same joke to a
different group of people
and you realize it's not as funny as you
thought it's just that french actually i
do want a girl who makes jokes that was
more of a luxury than an absolute
necessity in their relationship a
separate study found that men value
women who are pretty and
unfunny as more desirable than equally
pretty women who
are funny this can part i i can concur
i i've never found my humor to like
really help me
in dating honestly attributed to well
maybe maybe that's why me and my
boyfriend probably like each other but
outside of that
well never mind scratch that i
contradicted myself after i thought of
it the fact that we associate
humor with intelligence and this study
found that men find women less
attractive if they think that woman is
smarter than they are
finally this study found that men are
more likely to make jokes in mixed
company whereas women are more likely to
joke when only other women are around
honestly good to know do you guys have
like a very
specific quality that you look for in
men
ask a man how he feels about elon musk
because the venn diagram of men who
idolize elon musk
versus men who are condescending to you
even when you're right
is a circle i'm gonna explain something
and i want y'all to listen up what did
elon musk do
when i was four i was trampled by a dog
that was much bigger than me and ever
since then i've had a fear of dogs
that was 14 years ago and i've come
across many many sweet dogs
but still anytime i see a dog i get
panicked now let's talk about bees
lots of people are afraid of bees that's
a very common fear and even if you
haven't been stung by a bee people are
still scared of the idea of getting
stung
and i first got stung by a bee when i
was seven but i was still scared of bees
before that
but not all dogs are going to trample
you and not all bees are going to sting
you
so if i make a statement like dogs are
scary it's a given that
not all dogs are scary do you see where
i'm going with this
chances of getting hit by a dog are 1 in
73 chances of getting stung by a bee
are six million to one chances of
getting raped
one in five if any woman makes a video
about women's issues with men
don't you [ __ ] dare say not all men
those types of videos
yeah but this is this is what's not fair
about it is it's
a very small percentage of men that are
doing the like
the raping and plus i'm pretty sure that
stat
is inflated i don't remember how but i'm
pretty sure that stats inflated in some
level
but no i do not like matter trash
i do not think it's cool for girls to
say that and
no i that's not cool they're meant to be
educational and bring up issues that
women go through they're almost never
meant as a personal attack to you
it's only an attack if you make it one
it's women's history
okay what if guys says women are [ __ ]
my last girlfriend cheated on me all
these women are [ __ ]
how how about girls like that not all
girls
like no no so i'm gonna be talking about
some of my favorite historical medical
misconceptions about women's health
up first we have aristotle who falsely
claimed that women had less teeth than
men
and this one's kind of confusing to me
because i'm pretty sure aristotle had a
wife he could have just asked
and with our good friends the ancient
greeks we also have the concept of
wandering womb syndrome the idea that a
woman's uterus was a completely separate
entity from her and had the ability to
wander about within her body and take up
the space of other organs
but could be lured back to its
designated location with pleasant smells
and then green sickness a medical
condition only capable of affecting
virgins but don't worry it could go away
very easily by you know
doing it one of my personal favorites is
the belief that reading would make women
go sterile because it would draw blood
away from their reproductive organs into
their brains
but i'll tell you what i can't beat the
early critics of the train who believed
that women's bodies were not intended to
go 50 miles per hour and these
would fly out from their bodies due to
the speed high
speed gender-based trauma and i have two
relevant degrees from harvard on this
let's talk about men who say not all men
this behavior comes from three sources
first this is a male pick me behavior oh
i understand there are men
out there who are acting in abusive ways
but i'm not one of them
i'm one of the good guys that's a total
delusion by the way in a patriarchy
everyone will internalize misogyny
sexism and oppressive ways
to treat women that's what me what did i
do
why we all gotta unlearn patriarchal
ways of behaving
number two the need to control women's
voices i already like
i'm starting to tune her out notice how
they are tone policing women
no okay okay no no they don't tone
police women
you literally have youtube tick tock
twitter instru like there's so many
social media platforms where you can
literally say
pretty much anything you want no i'm not
more than they're mad at those men who
are abusing harassing and raping women
who are giving rest of the men a bad
name number three male superiority
complex this would relate to the male
pikmi behavior oh i understand there
will be awful men out there like who
will abuse and rape and harass you
and oppress you but i'm not one of them
if you depend on me
to protect you from male violence you'll
be good that instills in women a fear of
independence that the real solution to
the male violence
is another man bygone that's not true by
the way
[Music]
i'm the only one offering solutions look
at
i don't have a gun i don't even really
want a gun
my brothers have a lot of guns but i
just you know
but if i was really scared for my life
on a regular basis i would buy a gun
[Music]
jingle bell jingle bell
it's just gonna be the same
the laziest dance i've ever seen not i'm
not even a dancer
um okay um
that was a really stupid tick tock
compilation and
the i like i hate men men are trash like
it just irks me
i've been there i get it but literally
like
no it's not it's not cool and if you
have a brother
father or just male friend that you love
and care about it's not cool to say so
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
ring that notification bell and i will
talk to you guys next time